[Musique]
oh non
until donne traduit vulgairement par
jusqu'à l'aube est un jeu film
interactif d'horreur j'ai refoulé
récemment à celui ci et j'avais oublié à
quel point ce jeu était grand et bien
fait quel chef-d'oeuvre ce n'est pas
forcément un sujet de trois théories
auquel vous vous attendiez mais je tiens
réellement à rendre hommage à ce jeu
incroyable l'histoire parle d'une bande
de jeunes qui se retrouvent pour un
séjour annuel dans un chalet en montagne
appartenant à la famille de l'un des
membres
mais cette fois ci ils se sont retrouvés
pour fêter le premier anniversaire de la
disparition danaé baisse les deux soeurs
de josh qui possède la demeure mais tout
ne va pas se passer comme prévu car un
psychopathe essaiera de les tuer un à un
mais ce n'était pas sans savoir que ce
qu'il y avait dehors et beaucoup plus
terrible ce jeu est vraiment incroyable
et pourtant je n'aime pas vraiment les
jeux d'horreur celui-ci interagit par le
biais de nos choix avec l'effet papillon
en fonction de nos choix chaque
personnage peut mourir ou alors se
rapprocher des uns des autres sans
compter le fait que la sphère de la mort
des deux soeurs n'a jamais été élucidé
et le jeu nous fera réfléchir sur
l'histoire et ce qui s'est passé
l'ambiance le scénario ce jeu est tout
simplement grandiose du vrai génie et je
décide donc de vous parler de trois
théories que je vous propose
on va commencer par la théorie que j'ai
imaginé par incroyable mais je la trouve
intéressante tout le long de l'histoire
nous nous entretiendrons avec une sorte
de psychiatres celui ci nous interrogera
pour connaître nos peurs et analysera
notre façon de jouer tous ceux ci
déterminera l'ambiance du jeu
cependant le jeu ne nous interroge pas
réellement personnellement mais
interroge un personnage dans l'histoire
c'est josh je pense que la plupart
auront compris le psychiatre est en fait
dans la tête de josh tout ceci est le
fruit de son imagination et tout se
passe dans sa tête
cependant quelque chose m'interpelle
l'avez remarqué à quel point dans le jeu
le bureau du psychiatre se délabre fur
et à mesure à tel point que le docteur
abandonnera josh à son sort et s'en ira
bizarrement tout ceci se passe de façon
crescendo comme l'état mental de josh ce
dernier se voit de plus en plus
délirants et fous je vais aller
directement là où je veux en venir
et si le docteur était en fait son
médicament je m'explique tout le long du
jeu le docteur est là pour aider josh à
le supporter l'aider à s'en sortir mais
plus le temps passe plus le bureau
devient délabré le médecin méchant et
josh devient de plus en plus parano
cela montrerait que le médicament qui
représentait par le docteur est en train
de s'estomper et que les effets
permettant de garder josh stable se
dissipe et laisse place aux délires de
plus le jeu nous montre bien que le
médecin est dans la tête de josh que
c'est son imagination cependant aucun
humain ne peut s'autoréguler comme ça on
se conseille en lui même ce qu'ils
doivent faire ou comment aller mieux
du moins à cela ne correspond pas au
personnage de josh qu'en pensez vous
g
du coup j'ai pâques
k
non
si vous ne connaissez pas le jeu je vous
conseille de passer cette théorie car
elle va totalement vous spoil une till
dawn offert enquête et accessoirement
sur la mort des soeurs de john hannah et
baisse tragiquement tomber dans les
mines
cependant anna n'est pas morte sur le
coup et a survécu pendant des semaines
tout seul dans les mines sans réussir à
en sortir
vous devez connaître le processus de
malédiction du wendigo touche les gens
désespérés dans la montagne et qui ont
recours au cannibalisme
c'est ce qui s'est malheureusement passé
avec anna ayant survécu à sa chute pour
survivre elle a dû manger la chair de sa
soeur car ils étaient affamés et perdu
dans les mines
c'est pourquoi n'at s'est transformé en
wenzhou je ne montre bien que la
personne se transforme comme un zombie
infectés et que la personne meurt entre
guillemets de l'intérieur lorsqu'on
devient windigo on n'oublie pas comment
se comporter en tant qu'humain afin de
les imiter pour mieux les attraper nous
on ne devient plus qu'un simple
prédateurs avides de chair
nous en avons la preuve tout le long du
jeu avec les mineurs transformer et
n'ont plus aucune humanité et tuent tout
ce qui bouge si vous avez eu la fin
alternative donne-t-il down vous aurez
pu remarquer que lorsque josh est
confronté à allah ce dernier reconnaît
sa soeur grâce à son tatouage et du coup
vu que josh a reconnu sa soeur anna a
donc reconnu josh c'est l'effet papillon
et donc au lieu de tuer josh annales a
emmenées et lui a donné l'opportunité de
se transformer en wendy qu est la
rejoindre c'est ce qui se passera
anna a fait preuve d'humanité et à
épargner josh elle ne l'a pas tué cela
remet en cause totalement la nature des
one guigo après j'ai peut-être une
explication tous les autres windigo sont
des mineurs tués en 1952
nous sommes en 2000 environ tous les
wind hugo où environ 80 ans dont
cinquante ans en tant que wayne guigou
alors cadenas est la seule à avoir
seulement un an de vécu en windigo
peut-être que cela ne fait pas assez
longtemps et qu'elle est donc encore un
peu consciente de son passé d'ailleurs à
nay plus forte et plus en forme que les
autres windigo elle en tue même certains
la jeunesse plus forte que la vieillesse
on rigole mais c'est sûrement possible
n'hésitez pas à réagir là-dessus
non
pour finir nous allons parler d'une
courte et simple théorie mais je la
trouve tout de même intéressante
nous savons qu emilie et l'ex copine de
mike et qu'il est maintenant avec
jessica
cependant au début du jeu nous voyons ce
dernier flirtait encore avec emilie
avant de retrouver de jessica mike est
amoureux de deux fils
il possède encore des sentiments pour
emilie est il réellement amoureux de
jessica
cela se voit dans le jeu néanmoins un
certain moment du jeu et emilie se
prendre par un windigo et tout le monde
la soupçonnent d'en devenir pain nous
avons alors le choix en contrôlant
mailles de la tuer ou non le jeu nous
montre que mike que voudrais-tu et
emilie car il a peur qu'elle se change
en windigo cependant il ne le fait pas
par hasard il le fait qu'elle ne veut
pas la voir souffrir
mike le dit à la fin du jeu si vous avez
choisi de tuer emilie il est encore
amoureux d'elle cependant dans une pile
donne nous avons toujours le choix et
mike semble réellement divisée en deux
par l'amour qu'il porte à jessica et en
même temps celui qu'il porte pour emilie
c'est pourquoi je dirais que mike
pourrait alors tu fais emilie afin de
choisir celles qu'il aimerait garder
pour lui
jessica ou emilie mais ce qui ne colle
pas c'est que pour mike jessica est
morte depuis sa disparition
c'est pourquoi comme la plupart des gens
il ne choisit de ne pas la tuer car ils
n'y arrivent pas et souhaite garder
emilie qu'il aime encore
voilà je tenais réellement parler d'une
till dawn qui pour moi est un jeu
absolument incroyable de par son
scénario et son gameplay
je voulais lui rendre honneur et c'est
chose faite
votre façon de vous comporter est
déplorable je tenais à vous dire moi
vous proposons une nouvelle vidéo
théorie auquel j'ai passé beaucoup de
temps au montage à l'écriture notamment
pour ce texte
vous avez décidé de ne pas mettre de
j'aime ce qui a engendré la mort de deux
de vos amis j'adore les animaux
réellement pouvoir en tuer un sous mes
yeux n'a pas pu m'empêcher de vous
donner une certaine vengeance en tuant
mat
enfin je me suis dit qu'après vous deux
erreurs six ont été réellement je suis
allez vous poser la question la plus
profonde pour moi mais même ça vous
l'avaient dénigré
on récolte toujours ce que l'on sème et
vu que vous êtes en très mauvaise
posture
j'ai envie de vous dire que la vengeance
est un plat que je mange tout de suite
[Musique]